so we've been waiting for this by
administration releasing a long-awaited
report on migrant encounters at the
southern border during the month of
december it shows the number
trying to enter the u.s last month
higher than the three previous decembers
combined
bill mollusion on that story some
stunning video as well live in
brownsville texas wow bill good morning
bill good morning to you right now we
are in front of a parking garage in
brownsville where for the very first
time during this border crisis we
actually witnessed the mass release of
single adult male migrants from federal
custody take a look at this video we
shot right here on sunday afternoon what
you're looking at are federally
contracted buses dropping off dozens of
migrants at this parking garage and what
you'll quickly notice is these are all
single adults being released almost all
of them men no children no family units
and this raised eyebrows with us because
single adults are supposed to be
expelled from the country via title 42
so we watched these as these migrants
were ushered into this unmarked office
with a for lease sign there were some
black tarps set up outside uh to
restrict the public from viewing what
was going on and after a short time in
that office we started noticing taxi
cabs showing up to this parking garage
the la plaza parking garage we watched
as migrants then came out of the office
got into the taxi cabs and the taxi cabs
started driving away so we followed
those taxi cabs they ended up going to
harlingen airport about 20 to 30 minutes
away from where we are and those
migrants were just dropped off at the
airport to fly around the country we
talked to a couple of them they said
they were going to atlanta houston in
miami and they had just crossed
illegally and paid a cartel two thousand
dollars to do so so i reached out to the
city of brownsville to ask what the
heck's going on here and they confirm
they're involved take a look at the
statement if we can pull it up right now
city of brownsville telling me in part
quote in reference to migrants in
federal custody the city of
brownsville's office of emergency
management through federal assistance
from fema facilitates the transfer of
these migrants to their final
destination by allowing them to use
services to contact their families ngos
or a taxi cab la plaza parking garage
serves as a staging center where
migrants coming into the country are
provided with travel information to
facilitate transfer to their final
destinations they went on to tell me
that media is not allowed to go inside
and shoot video i reached out to cbp to
ask about the release of single adult
migrants they told me they were not
involved with this i reached out to ice
they told me they are looking into it
however a source within ice tells me
this was an ice release we'll send it
back to you well amazing stuff bill
malugion thank you it gets no better
from that story on the border